look if you're easily triggered or
offended this is not the video for you
you are going to get offended we're
going to talk about stereotypes last
week I'm in the Bahamas we took a couple
hundred of our executive sales leaders
there we're having dinner one night with
about 15 of us the couple sitting right
across from me he's the same person that
gave the Quran that I gave to Andrew
when I went to Romania he's a Muslim we
start having this conversation about
Muslim Christians stereotypes then all
of a sudden it led to stereotypes are
stereotypes accidentally given to
different sects or communities or
religions or ethnicities or is there
some truth behind these stereotypes he
says what do you mean by that he says
are you talking about that Muslims
terrorists violent I said that could be
one of them but why don't we play a game
here and see what everyone's gonna say I
look at everybody and I say give me the
most famous uncomfortable stereotypes
even some of them that are popular one
by one by one one guy says White Men
Can't Jump another guy says Armenians
aren't insurance fraud another person
says Germans drink a lot of beer French
are snobs Jamaicans love to smoke pot
Swedish people are hot older people suck
at technology Jewish people are cheap
Asians are great at math and science
science black people have the most
fatherless homes Asians don't drive well
Indians own 7-Elevens and gas stations
blacks can't be racist Republicans love
guns poor people are lazy rich people
are greedy so anyways look some if
you're Muslims some of the stuff you're
going to say that's cool that's cool
that's not cool I just say that some of
the stuff you're Christian gonna do oh
that's cool well that's not fair why'd
you say that we have data top five
countries and terrorism the last 50
years which countries marriage works at
which religion which countries are the
most angry as we've got so much
different things to look at but today's
topic a complicated one we're going to
talk about if some of these stereotypes
about Muslim is true or not
thank you
so if you give value out of this video
give it a thumbs up subscribe to the
channel let me get right into it so look
let's talk about stereotypes I can't
stand stereotypes because I'm Middle
Eastern I'm in the insurance industry my
parents got a divorce I got so many
different stereotypes so I'm filled with
a bunch of different stereotypes I've
been called every one of the things so
you're from around you must be a terror
you must be this all of them right but
I'm in the insurance industry I'm about
to start a company I'm on year two we're
about to go out of business I'm down to
my last thirteen thousand dollars I got
nothing else left to my name zero left
to my name we're going to this event
with AIG we're Napa Valley my son is
born he's six months old we're about to
go to this you know Excursion on how to
cook and bake I'm like babe you go with
my Dad I'm gonna stay at the hotel I'm
gonna spend some time with this kid I
haven't spent a lot of time with them
they go they go and they team up with
the guy that was running the entire
distribution of the company for AI big
company and they start having a
conversation together and he brings up
Armenians and he straight up asks my
wife hey how do you feel about Armenians
my wife is white she says what do you
mean how do I feel about Armenians how
do you feel about Armenians there's so
much Armenian Ensure fraud and there's
so much of it linked that we're going
through it at that time and a lot of
other companies were going through it so
she says you know my husband's Army and
he says I know and my dad is listening
to the conversation anyways they come
back I'm messing around with my son and
I hear them in the living room at Napa
talking
Memphis like I have to tell them before
he finds out after time she comes and
she says baby I've told you what just
happened he doesn't can't tell him so I
have to tell him what just happened such
and such person asked me how I feel
about Armenians because Armenians have
so much insurance fraud phone I'm
furious now the guy who said that ain't
lying that stereotype is actually true
in Glendale in many parts of LA you can
look this up many companies have gone
through this many different I personally
have some stories of that as well but I
don't like the fact that you judge me as
that but it's true partially with some
people in that industry so I come back
we go back to the office I'm calling
everybody I'm trying to find out what's
going to happen here all of a sudden I
found that him the same guy and their
lawyer from this company are flying in
just to meet with me my guy calls me my
rep and says Pat don't say anything they
may be terminating you today we're
sitting in this conference room in
Woodland Hills it's sitting right across
from me he says okay let me just get
right into it I said before you get
right into it I'd like to say something
this is what's that I said rumor has it
that you're uncomfortable with our our
meetings and I'm half our meeting and
because recently you guys had to lose
and write off millions of dollars of
insurance fraud and you're thinking I'm
going to do the same that makes me feel
very uncomfortable I'm sorry you're
going through it but here's what I'd
like you to do I'd like you to give me a
shot for one year to judge me based on
how I run a company not based on me
being half Armenian half a Syrian
formula there's a 20 second pause my
wife is sitting there moral is sitting
there I'm always sitting there all my
guys are sitting there and they're
sitting in the corner with the lawyer in
him takes a deep breath he says um okay
I get your point you have one year they
get up they leave fast forward six years
later the same man who had a stereotype
of what was going on with insurance
Judge Me based on that that is
retirement on a yacht had five people
speak at his retirement the last person
that spoke was his best friend the
second to the last person that spoke
with me we became best friends and I
respect this man so much why there is
truth here but our job on whatever sect
you are is to try try to change it so I
share this with you to tell you I've
been through it I don't like it and I
simply want to positively change it so
try to receive today's message in a way
where you're open-minded if you're
open-minded we can go through this
together again if you're not don't watch
the rest of it let's get right into it
so is The Stereotype of Islamic
extremism a fair stereotype according to
a study done by French Think Tank
islamist terrorist attacks account for
39.1 percent of the lives lost due to
terrorism Between 1979 and 2019. and a
matter of fact here's where the top five
countries are leading the way in
terrorist attacks the last 50 years Iraq
has experienced the most terrorist
attacks the last 50 years number two is
Afghanistan number three is Pakistan
number four is India the last but not
least in the fifth spot Syria okay so
you may say Pat give it a break this is
last 50 years how about recent no
problem I have that data for you as well
but I want you to be thinking about this
out of these five countries four out of
five are mainly Muslim countries and the
one that is not is India India is 80 and
Hinduism 14 Muslims so that's something
to be thinking about on what the
religion of those countries are well
let's look at 2021 when you look at 2021
top 10 countries in most terrorist
attacks Syria Afghanistan Dr Congo Iraq
Nigeria India Myanmar Pakistan Somalia
and Yemen and if you look at the
religion by each country Syria's 87
Muslim Afghanistan is 99.7 Muslim Dr
Kong was only 1.3 percent Muslim Iraq is
95 to 98 Muslim Nigeria is 50 Muslim
India is only 14 to 15 percent we talked
about it earlier mynamar is 4.3 percent
Muslim 96.5 Pakistan are Muslims in
Somalia it's 99 and in Yemen is 99 so
one may say well according to this I
mean that stereotype is true ain't it
okay fair now so now you may want to say
you miss it pat give it a break I mean
this is you don't want someone with the
West is down to the Middle East you
kidding me with everything with Israel
and Israel is getting all this funding
and they're backed up and of course
we're agitated we're angry we're this
okay somebody may say well fine if
that's the case Facebook your attacks
are within each you know how to say
black on black crime this is Iraqi on
Iraqi crime this is Afghani on Afghani
crime not all of it but most of it it's
happening internally so they said well
what's the history behind it how did the
Middle East get so violent and as a
matter of fact we pulled up who are the
most angriest people in the world Middle
Easterns are so Ingress so pull up the
data let's see what statistic Pew
research says about this and here's what
it actually says uh here we go so the
world's angriest countries number one is
Lebanon 49 number two is turkey 48
number three is Armenia 46 and some
tells me Armenians are going to be angry
because they're not number one on this
list that kind of made you angry right
apparently Armenians if you're watching
this we're angry now some of the
Armenians are watching this from Glenn
that are like I I don't know if I can
argue that because we are pretty angry
people sometimes Fair maybe we can call
it passionate number four is Iraq then
Afghanistan then Jordan then Mali then
Sierra Leone by the way and majority of
these countries are Muslim obviously not
Armenia it's a fair question to ask why
is it that the leading countries in the
world that are angry are Muslim majority
of them at least that's a fair question
to ask so let's take a look at the
history on why the Middle East is so
high Island the instability in the
Middle East started with the collapse of
the Ottoman Empire this is what the
Ottoman Empire looked like when it was
collapsed at the end of world war one it
was a deteriorating 600 year old Empire
entered World War One on the Central
Powers and that was the straw that broke
the camel's back by the way this is not
that long ago this is like maybe 100
years ago in 1960 1917 1918. look who
was in the Ottoman Empire when you look
at the map here Hungary Slovakia part of
it Croatia Serbia Romania Bulgaria
Moldova Ukraine turkey Georgia
Azerbaijan Iraq Syria Jordan Israel
Lebanon Egypt I mean I can't keep going
this is massive when you look at this
and the collapse of the Empire created a
power vacuum in the Middle East the new
borders in the Middle East after the
Ottoman Empire collapse were determined
by the sax Pico agreement this agreement
was between Britain and France that was
signed in 1916. the agreement divided
the Middle East into spheres of
influence for two countries Britain
would control Iraq and Palestine while
France would control Syria and Lebanon
so so if you look at the Sykes people
agreement writer you would notice that
the pink is the British rule the navy
blue is French rule and then you got the
Russian Rule and some of the other guys
that's out there but while this is going
on the bellafort Declaration a statement
is shown by the British government in
1917 promised to support the
establishment of a Jewish National home
in Palestine where they wanted a place
that was safe for them and at the same
time the League of Nations mandates a
system of international Administration
was created after World War one with
mandates that were granted to the
Victorious powers and they gave them
responsibility for governing the former
ottoman territories so in other words
the Western Powers played a major role
in determining the new borders in the
Middle East motivated by several factors
including their own strategic interest
the pursuit of oil and the desire to
protect the rights of the Jewish people
which by the way some people said with
the cpat all they wanted was our oil I
don't disagree you're right in Iran the
same thing happened British Petroleum in
Iran hey we own the oil jashar's like
what are you talking about this is oral
no no you need us without us you can't
do this yourself we're very smart we got
this you can kind of pump the brakes and
that kind of pissed off the British
Empire wait a minute you need us no no
we got this so that's the part that
there is a valid point of the argument
that the West kept trying to control
saying we know how to handle this you
don't know how to handle it without us
so this led to a role of determination
of the new borders in the Middle East
the Western Powers were aware of the oil
reserves in the region and they were
eager to control them this led to create
borders that would give them access to
the oil these borders did not reflect
the ethnic or religious divisions within
the region and this led to the rise of
sectarianism so if you've never heard
the word sectarianism think about
segregation segregation is by sects by
color communities by nationality
sectarianism is more by religion so
again it's not a positive word all you
religious people go here you guys go
here you guys go here kind of thing
right so SUNY and Shia are the two main
branches of Islam and they've been
divided for centuries the split between
the two dates back to the death of
Prophet Muhammad in 632 A.D after
Muhammad's death there was a
disagreement over who should succeed him
as a leader of the Muslim Community
Sunni Muslims believe the successor
should be chosen by the community while
Muslims believe that the successor
should be a descendant of Muhammad this
disagreement led to the split between
Sunni and Shia Muslims and it has been a
source of instability and conflict ever
since so like early we talked about the
Sykes Pico agreement this led to the
creation of states where large Sunni and
Shia populations that were controlled by
families appointed by the Western Powers
again authoritarianism and since then
this has led to endless civil war
between the two so while all this stuff
is going on in 1948 you know what ends
up happening Israel gets granted their
own country in the Middle East leading
to the Arab Israel war of 1948 which by
the way you know when the war happened a
day after the announcement of Israel
getting their own country May 15 1948 is
When The War Began a day after Israel
declared its independence so while this
was announced the Arab States invaded
Israel on all fronts but the Israelis
were able to repeal The Invasion and
even conquer some territories the war
ended on July 20th 1949 times lasted a
little over a year with the signing of
Artemis disagreement between Israel
Egypt Lebanon Jordan and Syria this led
to the displacement of hundreds of
thousands of Palestinians the war also
left a legacy of mistrust and animosity
between Israel and Arab states for
obvious reasons and its consequences are
still felt till today another fact here
to consider is the role that cold war
played in the instability of the Middle
East both the U.S and Soviet Union
supported different sides in the Arab
Israel conflict and this led to constant
proxy war similar to what's going on
right now with Ukraine and Russia where
U.S is kind of Defending Ukraine and
maybe China is defending Russia just
think about similar situations taking
place with what was taking place at that
time so obviously it doesn't stop there
over the next 70 years it's constant war
after war after War starting with the
1956 Suez Crisis a war between Egypt
France and the UK then you have the 1967
Six-Day War between Israel and the
Coalition or Arab states then you have
the 1973 Yom Kippur War a war between
Israel and Coalition of Arab states they
didn't have the 1979 Iran Iraq war which
was obviously between Iran and Iraq
leading after the revolution when the
Shah was in Exile and this war ended in
1988 a nine-year war by the way from
1979 to 1988. I lived in Iran in the
capital we got bombed it's a lot of
probably stop this really happened
that's a lot of agitation and anger that
this causes under people and it was
constant then in 1982 Lebanon war
between Israel and a coalition of
Lebanese and Palestinian forces this war
ended in 85. then you have the 1991 Gulf
War Between the Coalition of forces led
by United States and Iraq then you have
2003 Iraq war which lasted till 2011
with the withdrawal of U.S forces from
Iran then you have the 2006 Lebanon war
between the Israeli and Hezbollah the
war ended in the same year but no peace
agreement was ever reached and you have
the 2011 Syrian Civil War then you have
the 2014 to present yemeni Civil War
which eventually escalated into a proxy
war between Saudi Arabia and Iran the
war has caused a humanitarian crisis in
Yemen and again it has destabilized the
region when you think about this the
rise of Islamic terrorism over seven
year period this is like constant and
according to a 2022 study by Stockholm
International Peace Research Institute
the Middle East and North Africa region
has experienced the most Warfare in the
world the last 50 years and the study
found that the region has accounted for
38 percent of all armed conflicts
between 1970 and 2021 it also found that
the Middle East and North Africa region
has experienced the most fatalities for
Warfare the last 50 years study also
found that the region has accounted for
44 of all fatalities during that same
period so then I said let's take a look
at a couple other things you know when
it comes down to Islam as a religion
what is the overall divorce rate for
Islam versus others well the overall
divorce rate in America is roughly 39
right Protestants are 33 Catholics are
22 percent Muslims are 13 how often you
hear about Muslims getting a divorce 13
huh so they're big on family values and
maybe of the 20 000 people that
converted in America to Muslim Americans
75 are women fifteen thousand is that
what they value they want family values
they don't want the Muslim divorce and
all this stuff happening maybe that's
what it is so then I'm like okay so
marriages work out how many kids do
Muslims have then you look up the data
here again on pure research and no
matter what part of the world it is
Muslims lead the way with 2.9 babies per
women and Christians are second at 2 0.6
but if you go to every single region
sub-Saharan Africa number one Muslims at
around 5.2 Middle East North Africa
Muslims Leading The Way North America
Muslims in the way Asia Pacific Muslims
leading the way Europe Muslims leading
the way so then I'm sitting up we're
having a conversation together during
dinner I said so Muslims have to be
conservative and Republican right
because it's about family values it's
about marriage it's about kids it's a
strong faith conservative you're the
most intolerant towards lgbtq community
so what percentage of Muslims vote
Republican versus Democrat 70 percent of
Muslims were Democrat we're having a
conversations Pat it could be because of
Israel okay I can see the fact so are
you telling me Muslims in their mind on
the way they vote they're saying well
the fact that Republicans defend Israel
you know more you know it's we can't go
that route because we're Muslim but
we're also not about this lgbtq movement
that's taking place and we're about
family values so which way do we weigh
it do we weigh it out more of us being
Republican or Democrat and watch what
happened recently in 2018 Muslim
problems only 17 percent of them voted
Republican last year 2022 midterms you
know what percentage 28 it increased by
11 so maybe the last four years Muslims
are sitting there saying yeah I don't
know Democrats I mean I you know I
understand the fact that Israel is more
something that's on the other side but
now it's both of you guys uh I am no
longer feeling what Democrats stand for
so maybe Muslims are going through the
transition of wanting to say we relate
more to conservative Republicans more
maybe Independents way more than we do
Democrats today is that an evolution
that's taking place today who knows
that's what the data says according to
Wall Street Journal you understand why
I'm going with my thought process is
going right I'm processing this for
myself and and at the same time I'm
looking at the some of the churches
Christian churches in America like one
of them being thousands of Methodist
churches flee over Rift what's going on
this is an article from Christian Post
in the last couple months thousands more
houses of worship have left the United
Methodist Church having their
disaffiliation votes approved by their
UMC conferences updated total shows that
as many as 6 000 churches have fled the
UMC in the last couple years that's a
lot of churches and the issue shows no
signs of slowing down and even a
Christian Post reporter Michael
Grabowski said the following for the
last several decades the United
Methodist Church has been in a big
debate about whether to change its
official stance on lgbtq issues
currently the UMC prohibits the blessing
of same-sex unions and the ordination of
non-celibate homosexuals so methodists
are sitting there saying well the
direction you're going you're being a
little bit too comfortable with lgbtq
that's not part of our religion
Christians are going through it
Catholics are going through it I have
one my guys today send me a picture
about a big church in DC that has a big
pride flag this is the National City
Christian Church from DC this is taking
place at the same time recently Bishop
Strickland keeps pushing the envelope
he's out of Tyler Texas and he's on the
heels of apostolic visitation the pope
is not happy that this Bishop from the
Catholic church is pushing the fact that
we shouldn't be lgbtq so then are
Muslims conservative Christians
somebody's real Conservative Catholics
are coming together and saying listen
we're tolerant to one lot of things we
are not tolerant to lgbtq being okay
with all this other stuff maybe Muslims
conservative Christians and these guys
are finding each other kind of weird
they're sitting there saying listen I'm
against the rising number of teenage
pregnancies Muslims are not for that I'm
against abortions Muslims aren't for
that I'm against single mothers Muslims
are important that I'm against the
Meltdown of the family unit Muslims
aren't for that and neither are the
strong Christian conservatives maybe
these guys have a lot more in common
except who they believe is their Prophet
Jesus or Muhammad if we set that aside
you see kind of where this is going
weird right could there be a
I don't know
never thought this would take place
maybe it is so it's crazy when you think
about this right this whole thing got
started with stereotypes as long as
Muslims are all this or something okay
maybe Christians or black people these
white people and some other time what
would happen if they unified and they
got United together you go to your
church I go to my church but listen when
it comes down to these values we got to
protect these in America we may have
escaped Iran or Middle East or whatever
to come here because of the chaos but I
definitely didn't leave there because of
my conservative Muslim beliefs I think
both Christians and Muslims can kind of
pick up and say that's kind of what you
guys do right and that's kind of what
you guys do right it's kind of what we
did wrong we became too tolerant and
that's kind of what you guys did right
you were kind of intolerant towards
compromising some of these values all in
all one may say many of these
stereotypes are right but how about we
do something to change it I think that's
a better place to start okay today so if
you got value out of this video give it
a thumbs up subscribe to the channel but
another thing I want you to be thinking
about is we're taking the podcast live
on the road to talk to parents in
different city is the first place I'm
going to is Glendale California I went
to school there's USD so if you're a
parent you want to stay close to us
based on some of the topics we're
talking about text to work parents to
310-340-1132 to stay in contact so if we
come to your city we'll text you and
aside from that I did a video last week
about lgbtq history I got a lot of
commentary if you've not seen it click
here to watch it take everybody bye-bye
foreign
[Music]